blue industrie crée des analyseurs de
gaz pour permettre à ses clients de
limiter leurs émissions polluantes et
d'améliorer leurs procédés de production
dans le cadre du plan de relance elle va
bénéficier de trois cent mille euros
ils vont servir d'abord à faire des
investissements de matériel parce qu'on
a on a besoin de nouvelles technologies
pour pouvoir accélérer notre notre
développement est aussi de préparer le
déménagement dans de nouveaux locaux
ce qu'on va développer une nouvelle
unité de production pour pouvoir
fabriquer plus d'analyseurs et avoir un
rythme de production beaucoup plus
important
des fonds qui lui permettront aussi
d'embaucher une vingtaine de personnes
lancée en 2010 blue industrie lançons
premier analyseur en 2018
elle s'est portée candidate au fonds de
soutien à l'accélération de
l'investissement industriel
territoriales ont cherché à ce type de
l'entreprise parce que on sait tous que
la période économique difficile que la
france est face à un défi qui est
considérable et il est temps maintenant
grâce au plan de relance de construire
l'économie de demain et l'économie de
demain elle aura une part industrielle
13 projets sont déjà lauréat dans la
région ile de france dont quatre dans
les yvelines
le fonds atteindra 400 millions d'euros
d'ici à 2022